our PR firm is called publizity let's
place a very means you've milk boy shut
up with I don't want to say anything too
early because I don't want it to be like
a lady about it cuz that's like my vibe
but like honestly the cats like pretty
much out of a barn and like what I'm
pregnant your first challenge is sexy
fruit eating so you better bring your
a-game or you're gonna get an H begin
the Sanitation Department can we say she
wasn't found in a pile of trash fine
warm chill appear so huh I'm bad parents
will be better with trash
[Music]
mr. Cena rad looking for a nanny yes
loan here for the job interview you've
got three boys you're looking for a
nanny uh-huh and I'm a nanny and Here I
am
yeah well no so I just little did you
know that you would be pranked with too
much tuna so tell us about yourself well
I've been working for ten years
ha ha ha what is this what did you order
what has been placed what did you you so
are they they're not coming the children
hey I was wondering Collette would you
be against being my partner at the maple
games tonight of course a well I'll see
you there oh cool pardon me
awesome that's really exciting okey
pardon I guess I've got a date a date
with intercourse
[Music]
all right now clearly talented and you
got that x-factor but unfortunately okay
sorry
look I got emotionally involved and my
daughter was murdered times to my
beautiful wife who I love more than
anything in the world she was killed to
yourself I lost my sister to murdered no
children and may I ask you a question
and I don't I don't mean to be rude do
you have in memento disease because
every two minutes is there a job is
there kids there's no kids is no job
there's too much tuna you're on a prank
show right would you sign a release okay
listen up everybody
Sam rules is last year you want to go
out you tap your tree gather your SAP
and the first coupling to bring back one
liter of maple syrup
when's your new tips on tap in that SAP
oh no I listen to the rules very
intently so no thank you though talk
about SAP talk about sex oh no I went to
nurse teacher I put a squid in my exit
so I'm good to go
Oh bleep bleep bleep ooh bleep bleep
bleep is it over is it over because I
loved it welcome back to Upper Peninsula
State closed-circuit TV from time to
time we wire guys on the court refs on
the court just to hear what's going on
behind the scenes check it out man nice
to meet you I'm Jeff yeah Rhonda man
Rodney man just wash my hands for some
bathroom it's gonna be fun that all
right because you're crying tears I'm
giving you immunity and I just decided
that right now oh come on I love it when
Bobby gets jealous sometimes having high
emotions pays off the father of the baby
is a toilet baby c-czar and like i care
who knows that except for like most of
the people that i know like i don't want
them to know cuz I'm like horrified by
it and like very embarrassed consider
give me the bucket
[Music]
I just keep throwing off you should have
taught some guys what oh the stuff who
can never be sure
extraordinary
[Music]
feels like denise has been going for
canines when she really deserves ak10
well Denise hopefully this show can get
you barking up the right tree we set up
a fun little mingler for Denise to meet
some new friends I've mostly been with
pugs hope that doesn't bother you
oh no denise is going about this all
wrong you're not gay right good anis I'm
open to bisexuals and australian I can
tell by your body language that you're
upset I don't know how to swim okay it's
just ironic because I was born in a
toilet water and then I couldn't bend
unhappy able to go swimming I feel
stupid in Barrie's like that time I took
a do give my pants we've all been there
this is our I took a Dookie in my pants
in first grade and they were corduroys
of course I'm charmed I'm sure Gil
faizon and i am also at the same time
charmed I'm sure george st. geegland
we're the hosts of televisions too much
tuna but there's nothing tuna about
joking around over a billion people die
mercury poisoning every year while
you're peeing little chunks of tuna fish
come out then you've probably got an
issue that girl said this girl's dead
that girl's dead that girl's you know
they're doing a great time
full-service wedding service commercial
you've gotta hire me to handle your
wedding gonna get it right it's like
gonna bring it whether it's not a cover
throw you know what everyone had a fun
time so I'm happy I recommend them to
anyone okay I say very much with
professionalism call now via text
message and I'll get back to you with a
very professional thing
you